who they kill when they kill them you
never know what's going to happen why
don't we start Greeks can you tell us
what you basically priests are afraid of
whether I'm going to be naked again you
have no idea when you're gonna be naked
it just you just turn the page and it
says no whether I have to go to a gym or
not okay mazie what about you do you try
and ever talk to the writers and get
hints about please tell me I'm gonna be
okay this season I start asking them and
then I feel like I'm being annoying I
think maybe I shouldn't ask them because
I end up dead quicker and then I came to
suckin up to them and I'm like like you
know buy your drink or it's gonna go out
some food and then I'm like am I still
being annoying and I don't really know
how to get around the death thing but
I'm doing alright so you're doing okay
so far I got it no it has been I've
heard that the writers and producers can
be cruel and I heard that alfie they
pranked you with a script they they sent
gave you a script that was a fake script
just to freak you out tell us that story
they did well I just had no tact I was
asked from the whole season whether I
was gonna die on up because we get the
scripts in a way where we get a episodes
one six and then we'll get the last four
later on so I asked them and they were
just like shrugging their shoulders sort
of give me that and then I I went on
holiday I had a three week break and
I've been given this fake script where
it was my bran comes out and back of
holes back in Winterfell
and says this is my Winterfell not yours
and stabs me in the hearts and so I
thought it's a great way to go boy have
you memorable and they called me up when
I was on a holiday saying so how do you
like your ending do you like it knows
that yeah it's cool thanks guys they're
like okay cool how would you feel about
her being a zombie next year he's right
yeah I can do that okay how would you
feel about being a zombie with
absolutely no dialogue whatsoever I
don't really like come on man you be
serious oh yeah they can't be kind of
cruel with it that's not just kind of
cruel that is so none of that it was all
BS they didn't mean any of it and you
you still got a job John do you worry
about getting pranked I do but my worry
is that we're under estimating these
guys and my worry is that a lot of
people have been prank saying that
they're gonna die my worry is that
you're gonna get 10 scripts and that
you're gonna have dynamite stuff there's
going to be there's going to be scenes
with people you've never had seen me
before
amazing narrative arc you're gonna win
Murray's the hero of the piece the day
after
please find script amendments for
episodes 1 to 10 changes made your honor
in a single frame of it is that possible
could that happen they could do that
they simply whatever they want okay
Sophie Sansa has been through a lot just
so much before this is not real folks
Andy no oh sorry is real baby well
you've been through so much and before
the season even begins it feels like
unrelenting are you hoping that this
season things start to get a little
cheerier I mean we all know but I'm just
thinking you can have one episode where
they're like that's a good cookie you
know why can't there be one episode
where they're like I had a good night's
sleep
me too anyone get killed not a one oh
yeah next and then resume next week yeah
and then we can all do like a village
yeah yeah
I like that song
it's original okay I have to ask you
something Maisie you shot how many for
so long your character was in filming
and miserable kind of cold conditions
right were you jealous that your camera
I got to be filming in beautiful just
look like a beautiful spa the whole crew
including Sophia number of the cast
members would disappear for like six
weeks and then come back and like yeah
we had a really amazing time in Croatia
it was so much fun and so he wouldn't
show me all the videos like oh we were
just like playing in the ocean I really
like really really mean actually it hurt
me so when I was told that this year I
was going to create Croatia and Suki was
I was totally thrilled there was not a
single ounce like of my body that felt
bad at all I was like you know I'm gonna
have an amazing time in Croatia without
you hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy japanese
pornography